- What up?
Sunday morning,
another #BizDevSunday.
I'm excited.
Justin looks like he's dead.
("Monday To Monday" by Saba)
Saba, I've been telling you.
Looks like there's
a dead man behind me.
Justin Novello,
brother-in-law extraordinaire.
Brother-in-law extraordinaire,
there we go.
Anyway, Jordan.
- 'Sup guys?
- We'll get into the biz
dev aspects in a second.
It's been going extremely well.
A lot of good action going on.
And I've got some
good ones this week.
So looking forward to it.
Here we go.
GaryVee.com/AreYouDRock
(bell dings)
That's right,
we because of VaynerTalent,
because of our
small business division,
because of my brand
and because of all
my entrepreneurial
wants and needs
of maybe doing this for
other A-list entrepreneurs
or celebrities or
different things outside
of VaynerTalent world
or the next brand I buy
or one of these seven-figure
businesses I get into
last week and we decide
the founder needs to be
the face of the business,
we are on a mission
to collect more DRocks.
Tyler Babin, yes,
Justin, others.
Portuguese kid
that dominates, amazing.
They're out there.
There are tens of thousands
of DRocks in my opinion.
He's the best
and he's incredible
but these what are called
I guess in that world predators.
People that want to
film, edit, do the whole thing.
Kit and caboodle.
Like you're the whole
production company in one.
You're a kid that since seven,
have been hacking and
mix and matching.
YouTube videos, you love Vimeo.
You play, you understand how to
make meme videos on Instagram.
You're a video production
2017 ninja predator.
If you're one of those people
and you want to come
and work at our place,
entry level job, three months,
learn it. Learn it with us.
Learn the DRock way,
learn the Babin way,
learn the way Dunk, Andy and
I and the whole world see it.
And then spin out and
work at VaynerTalent
or small business or
at VaynerMedia or
stay on our team 'cause
we love you so much.
We are looking for them.
Click the link below,
send your message.
There's a form,
you'll fill it out.
Be smart about
how you fill it out.
There should be a
lot of entries on this.
Lot of people claim
to be a DRock, prove it.
Okay, so a bunch of you
want your music on DailyVee.
Please submit the form
GaryVee.com/MusicForGV
(bell dings)
link right here.
Well, link's in
the video description
but the URL is right there.
Bunch of you talking
a lot of shit on social
that you got the fattest beats,
prove it to us. Submit it.
Looking for a lot more music
for DailyVee in the future.
It's a great way, hit up
your homies who are in it.
Great way to get some exposure.
Obviously a lot of
artists have been benefiting.
(bell dings)
Alright, great Sunday
with the boys.
Great Biz Dev Sunday.
Go spend some time
with your boys and girls.
See you tomorrow.
(light music)